Und das ist es.
Und das ist es. Und das ist es. Und das ist es.
Dennis Krüggs von Erdgeist vom CCC sind hier. Ihr seid eingeladen mit anzurufen, zu diskutieren und Fragen zu stellen unter der 0331 70 97 110.
Und das hat Thomas gemacht, namen Thomas.
Grüß dich, von wo rufst du an?
Aus Hannover, alles klar. Super.
Und zwar habt ihr auf dem letzten 24C3 davon berichtet, dass ihr einen IP-Adressen Zufriedsgenerator eingespielt habt. Und ihr hattet ja auch eure Software an PirateBay weiter in dem. Und da wollte ich mal nachhaken, ob dieser IP-Zufriedsgenerator auch bei PirateBay funktioniert oder läuft.
Okay, also die Sache ist die, dass wir nennen es jetzt mal hier die Mitfahrtzentrale, dass auch nicht nur du dort Informationen kriegst, wer eine bestimmte Datei tauscht, sondern sagen wir mal, wenn da jemand ermittelt oder so die Musikfilmindustrie oder ein Spielhersteller, der kann halt auch dorthin gehen und wenn da ein Spiel getauscht wird zum Beispiel, dann können die sagen, gib mal alle Adressen, die aktuell dieses Spiel irgendwie tauschen. So, da wären dann irgendwie alle Adressen dabei, zum Beispiel auch deine. Und damit würden die dann irgendwie loswandern und würden dich irgendwie, was schicken die heutzutage, eine Abmahnung oder irgendwie, irgendwann schicken sie dir halt einen Brief und so damit die halt keine 100%igen Beweis haben, mischen wir halt eine Zufalls IP-Adresse mit rein. Mal machen wir es, mal nicht, kann man nicht wissen und die wissen es auch nicht. Das heißt, die könnten deine Adresse bekommen haben, weil wir die zufällig erstellt haben. Das heißt, du könntest wiederum sagen, wenn die zu dir kommen, kann ja sein, dass ihr meine Adresse habt, aber von mir ist die nicht. Und wenn euch mehr erkundigt, die Jungs haben die da einfach per Zufall reingemixed. Ich warte gar nicht und mehr ist das nicht. Das läuft nur da. Das ist im Code auch nicht drin, weil den haben wir selber zusammengehackt, weil den soll halt keiner haben. Das machen wir so, wie wir es halt denken nicht, dass die unseren schlechten Zufallscode knacken und dann beweisen können, wie wir auf den gekommen sind oder irgendwie so. Deswegen gibt es den nur bei PirateBay, wenn du bei uns unseren Sourcecode auscheckst, von dem OpenTracker nämlich, kann man gleich noch erzählen, dann ist der nicht mehr drin. Da kann sich auch jeder selber reinbasseln. Das ist ja ganz easy. Du brauchst einfach dir nur eine IP-Adresse einfallen lassen und dann schmeißt du die da rein und lieferst die mit aus. Und das war es schon so. Eine andere Frage, die du noch vorhin gestellt hattest, die hast du jetzt, glaube ich, unterschlagen war, ob wir denn das UDP-Protokoll mit unterstützen in unserem Trecker oder halt auch PirateBay. Und das ist der Fall. Wir unterstützen das schon seit einem Jahr jetzt und läuft auch ziemlich prima. Also kann man nur empfehlen, weil UDP macht weniger Last für den Trecker als TCP, weil wenn man mal Zahlen nennt von PirateBay, die sind bei 25 Millionen Nutzern gerade und UDP ist irgendwie drei bis viermal weniger Traffic so in der Richtung und das spart denen eine Menge irgendwie Traffic, CPU-Zeit, müssen sie weniger Rechner kaufen und die bei PirateBay verdienen auch nicht wirklich viel. Also gar nichts eigentlich an der Sache, sondern die müssen das auch irgendwie zusammensponsoren. Na, das läuft überhaupt nicht, weil die dürfen halt auch kein Geld verdienen.
Erzähl doch mal, was PirateBay ist erstmal, Dennis.
Ja, dann sind wir aber auch fertig mit dir, glaube ich, als Hörer. Tut mir leid.
Das war jetzt so im Schnelldurchlauf. Zack, Zack, Zack, Zack, Zack, Info. Danke, Aled. Klar, mach's gut.
Ja, tut mir leid, aber das ist ja dann schon ein nächstes Thema, aber du hörst ja weiter zu. Okay. Eiskalt, ja.
Es war PirateBay viel, also mit dem Tracker, das haben wir jetzt, glaube ich, zu genüge erklärt.
Wir erklären dir, du kommst ja auch noch weiter vor.
Der OpenTracker ist ja auch noch dran.
Genau, also es gibt, wir erwähnen mal PirateBay, was ist PirateBay? Und zwar, wenn du jetzt deinen Sportfilmen hier von deinem Verein, wenn du den halt irgendwie hochladen willst.
Ich mach nicht mal Sport, aber ein Beispiel ist schön.
Ja, wie hoch nicht man. Sport ist Mord, haben wir gestern erst wieder gelernt. Du willst dann deinen Vereinsfilm irgendwo hochladen und denkst dir, alles klar, gucken wir mal, googeln wir so nach Trackern, kommt gleich irgendwie PirateBay, weil PirateBay selbst, wenn man keinen BitTorrent benutzt, alle Leute kennen PirateBay, das sind irgendwie die guten, für manchen sind es auch die total Bösen, je nachdem, das sind die mit dem Piratenschiff vorne auf der Website.
Also um es einfach zu sagen, PirateBay ist einfach quasi so ein Sammelbecken, wo ich nach Torrent suchen kann.
Da kannst du nach Torrent suchen. Genau, das Google der Torrents. Und damit du da suchen kannst, müssen die Torrent-Files ja da auch hinkommen. Also nimmst du dann dein Sportfilm Torrent und lädst das bei PirateBay hoch, die Liste ist dann und dann kann man danach suchen. Dann tippt man ein hier Sportfilm Torrent und dann zack kommt genau dein Torrent-File, klickt man drauf, lädt man das Torrent-File runter, startet es mit seinem eigenen BitTorrent-Client und dann fängt er an. So, da drin ist natürlich auch der...
Das funktioniert aber nur, wenn diese File bei denen komplett ist.
Genau, du musst dieses kleine BitTorrent-File hochladen. Das ist irgendwie, sagen wir mal so, 200 Kilobyte groß, während dein Film, sagen wir mal so 700 Megabyte groß ist. Und das können die schnell mal ausliefern, auch an 10.000 Leute 300 Kilobyte ausliefern, ist kein Problem. So, das laden dann alle runter und dann legen sie los. Und wenn du als Tracker zum Beispiel auch wieder PirateBay eingetragen hast, weil die haben halt ganz viele davon, dann wird auch deren Tracker benutzt. Und deswegen können die auch auf ihrer Webseite anzeigen, das Torrent-File wird gerade von irgendwie 17 Leuten komplett schon angeboten, weil die haben es schon komplett da und 35 laden es irgendwie runter. Dann haben die so ein bisschen Statistiken und so. Die haben dann ein Kommentarsystem für das Torrent. Da kannst du reinschreiben, was ist das für ein scheiß Sportmovie? Oder ist ja voll super klasse.
So was nennen die Sport?
Oder wie kann ich denn hier diesen Film abspielen? Die quatschten ja Deutsch, ich verstehe keinen Ton. Weil PirateBay ist halt in Schweden und so eine Sachen haben.
Aber hatte PirateBay, um das nochmal ganz kurz auszugreifen, hatten die in der Vergangenheit nicht immer wieder Ärger?
Die hatten immer wieder Ärger, weil halt, kann man so sagen, weil die der größte Trecker, der größte Torrent-Suchmaschine weltweit sind und immer noch. Und dann kommt natürlich die Filmindustrie an und will die wegklagen, weil da gibt es natürlich irgendwie alle möglichen Movies auch noch irgendwie vor der Veröffentlichung oder kurz danach.
Aber die liegen ja, wenn ich das jetzt nochmal als Sendung mit der Mausidiotenfrage dazwischen stellen darf.
Jetzt kommt das entscheidend, ich weiß schon, was jetzt kommt.
Nee, aber die Files liegen ja nicht bei PirateBay auf einem Server, sondern die sind ja bei Usern über die ganze Welt verteilt. Und niemand würde ja auf die Idee kommen, Google zu verklagen. So sieht's aus. Oder irgendeine andere Suchmaschine, weil du bei denen sagst, zeig mir mal bitte ein Foto vom Büro vom Chaos Computer Club.
Und die bei Google haben sogar noch viel mehr, weil die haben ja wirklich, die cashen ja irgendwie Teile der Seiten, wobei es jetzt wirklich nur ist ein bisschen Text, aber die bei PirateBay, die haben wirklich nur noch dieses Torrent-File, wo Prüf-Summen von dem eigentlichen Film oder der eigentlichen Datei drin sind, aber die haben nicht die Datei selber, die haben die auch nie gesehen, nie angefasst. Die wissen auch nicht, wenn du anstelle von deinem Sportfilm da einen... Jugendradio, irgendetwas anderes reinmachst, das wissen die nicht. Die wissen nur, da sind so Prüf-Summen drin und das soll wohl so heißen, aber alles andere interessiert die nicht. Und der Trecker, der das nachher handelt und die einzelnen Leute miteinander verbindet später, der weiß eigentlich noch viel weniger, weil der kriegt irgendwie nur so einen langen Hasch, 20 Zeichen. Mehr weiß der nicht.
Die Frage, die vielen Leuten auf der Zunge liegt, ist, ist das Benutzen von Torrent-Clients und PirateBay legal?
Ja, würde ich auch sagen, das Benutzen an sich ist legal. Wenn du natürlich da böse Sachen machst, die weltweit geahndet werden, dann kommen die natürlich, dann sind die hinter dir her. Aber auch der von PirateBay, der ist da ziemlich schmerzlos, dem ist das alles egal. Da gab es letztens den Fall, der hat sich da echt keine Freunde gemacht, aber der ist halt auch ein bisschen, setzt sich da durch, wurden glaube ich die Obduktionsfotos eines kleinen Mädchens, was in Schweden irgendwie zu Tode gekommen ist, die auch immer sind, bei PirateBay gelandet. Und der Vater hat halt darum gebeten, dass die da drunter genommen werden.
Verständlicherweise.
Peter, ja, wenn man länger drüber nachdenkt, vielleicht dann irgendwann nicht mehr. Also ich hab auch gedacht, muss er jetzt nicht sein, dann dachte ich irgendwann, aber wenn er irgendwo mit einer Sache anfängt, dann drunter nimmt er, irgendwann muss er tausend Sachen runternehmen, das geht halt irgendwie nicht. Und laut Gesetz ist es auch legal in Schweden, so eine Fotos, Obduktionsberichte sind für jeden frei zugänglich. Das ist eine ganz normale Sache da in Schweden. Deswegen konnten die PirateBay auch noch nicht dicht machen, weil PirateBay an sich ist auch legal in Schweden, in Deutschland weiß ich gar nicht, ob es legal wäre.
Also wenn ich PirateBay in Schweden nutze, ist alles cool in Deutschland.
Wenn du das von hier aus nutzt, ist halt die Frage. Das kommt ja auch immer noch auf den Inhalt an. Wenn du da irgendein illegales Spiel runterlädst und das ist ein deutsches Spiel und die deutsche Firma ist dahinter her, dann sind die hinter dir her. Wenn die das irgendwie mitkriegen, kommt die halt an PirateBay nicht an.
Aber das macht ja doch keiner. Es geht ja nur darum, den Sportfilm runterzuziehen.
Gibt es auch Leute, da gibt es auch ab und zu mal Ärger. Es gibt ja in Amerika immer Fälle, wo die da so ein bisschen rumklagen. Und noch ein paar Userzahlen will ich rausführen, weil wir haben die ja gerade so.
Dann kommen wir zu Emil, der hat angerufen.
Da gibt es 25 Millionen aktive PirateBay-Nutzer und die haben anderthalb Millionen Torrents gelistet, aktiv immer so pro, also jetzt so. Also jetzt gerade hat PirateBay 1, 5 Millionen Torrents, die sind irgendwie, worum sie sich kümmern. Das sind morgen wieder andere, aber immer noch so anderthalb Millionen.
Ich glaube, Emil hat Blutgeleck, der hat uns nämlich angerufen unter 0331 70 97 1S0. Name, Emil. Grüß dich. Du hast eine technische Frage zum Thema Server.
Genau.
Schieß los.
Ja, wie richtet man sich eigentlich so ein Server zu Hause ein? Also wenn ich jetzt eine eigene Webseite machen möchte, wie stelle ich die sozusagen ohne ein Hoster ins Internet?
Na, die können dir sagen, such dir irgendwie dünn den, erst mach den Account und dann weiß ich nicht, wenn du noch eine Frage zu BitTorrent hast, können wir dir helfen, ansonsten ist es gut, passt gut.
Ja und wie packt man überhaupt BitTorrent auf diesen Server auch auf? Also dass alle Leute dann diese Dateien haben können, ohne dass man jetzt PirateBay oder so verwendet.
Also um nochmal auf die Frage zurückzukommen, um das Beispiel nochmal zu benutzen, ich habe einen Film gedreht, hab den jetzt, der steht bei mir, liegt bei mir auf meinem Computer, auf meiner Festplatte und ich möchte den dann alle Leute verteilen.
Und der will jetzt seinen eigenen Tracker aufmachen. Na dann lädst du dir einen Tracker deiner Wahl runter. Wir würden natürlich unseren OpenTracker empfehlen. Komplirierst du den, also baust du den für dein Betriebssystem. Wo kriege ich den, den OpenTracker? Da muss Erdgeist die Adresse durchpusten.
Einfach in Google einladen, der zweite Hit ist es.
Bei Google OpenTracker und BitTorrent ein, dann müsste der eigentlich irgendwie mit Eiffel Lucky kommen. Dann startest du den und trägst deine eigene Adresse dann sozusagen als mitfahrzentrale Adresse für den BitTorrent, wie sagt man, für den BitTorrent-File ein.
Dit, BitTorrent-File.
Dit, BitTorrent-File. Ich bin Berliner.
Dit-Torrent.
Emil, Frage beantwortet. Ihr könnt natürlich auch Fragen stellen. Wir haben jetzt schon kurz über PirateBay gesprochen. Wir haben den OpenTracker eben gerade erwähnt. Vielleicht noch mal drei, vier Szenen zum Thema OpenTracker.
Das geben wir jetzt wirklich mal an den Erdgeist, weil der hatte ja zusammengeschustert und deswegen das ist ja sein Baby.
Viel gerade Handarbeit wahrscheinlich.
Schußt dann auch.
So, Erdgeist, OpenTracker. Wir haben vor zwei Jahren angefangen, waren wir der Meinung, dass BitTorrent ein total cooles Medium ist, so Dennis und Krüggs und ich. Und dass man allen zur Verfügung stellen sollte, die Dateien miteinander austauschen wollen. Die sollen BitTorrent benutzen können. Und damals war es so gewesen, dass man die ganzen Tracker, die es gab, nur benutzen konnte, wenn man sich vorher angemeldet hat.
Sogar PirateBay musste man sich immer erst anmelden und man durfte auch nur deren Tracker irgendwie benutzen, sonst durfte man bei PirateBay keine Filesuche landen.
Genau, es war ziemlich blöd. Dann haben wir gesagt, stellen wir mal eine eigene Version von so einem BitTorrent-Tracker ins Internet. Und haben den von Bram Cohn genommen, der irgendwie in Python geschrieben war. Und naja, da hat sich durch Mundpropaganda weiterverteilt, dass man da diese Midware-Zentrale benutzen kann. Und alle Leute, die da mal schnell eine Datei austauschen wollten, haben dann den genommen. Und dann wurde das immer größer und größer. Und das schon bei Dennis in der Küche. Und der Server wurde ganz heiß und dann haben wir gesagt, mh?
Meine Leitung war dann irgendwann dicht. Da ging nichts mehr, nur durch Treckeranfragen.
Genau, weil wenn halt nur genug Leute kommen und genug Leute andere Leute suchen, dann macht das plötzlich auch wieder Verkehr. Also sind wir dann auf einen anderen Server umgezogen. Und der war dann auch bald dicht. Und zwar auf eine Art und Weise, dass halt das Programm einfach so langsam gewesen ist. Und da so eine Mitvertragung nicht viel zu tun hat, als irgendwie Verbindungen annehmen, das einzutragen und wieder was rauszugeben und das irgendwie auch über das HTTP-Protokoll macht, also das, was in einem Browser normalerweise auch spricht, hab ich dann leichtsinnigerweise gesagt, das ist ja halt nur ein Web-Server, das kann man mal schnell selber programmieren. Naja, dann hab ich mich da hingesetzt und das mal schnell selber programmiert und dann...
Du hast das Wort leichtsinnigerweise benutzt und mal schnell selber programmiert.
Also die erste Version war schon nach zweieinhalb Wochen fertig, aber da ist ja immer noch was zu tun. Und naja, also wir haben das Programm dann gestartet und hatten uns dann erst gewundert, ob es denn überhaupt läuft, weil es dann einfach nicht mehr aufgetaucht ist in der Prozesslast- Ansicht. War halt einfach dann immer in C und nicht in Python geschrieben und war dann gleich mal um Größenordnung schneller. Und dann war ich erst mal eine Weile stolz und hab nichts mehr gemacht und dann irgendwann waren es dann doch so viele Leute gewesen, dass man dann nochmal optimieren musste. Da waren dann sowas wie mehrere tausend Leute, die dann pro Sekunde einfach mal bei dieser Mitfahrtzentrale vorbeigekommen sind. Und inzwischen war dann auch der Server, den wir uns dafür gemietet haben. Da kam dann der Host da, bei dem wir den Rechner hingestellt haben, kam an und die wollten auch seriös Geld sehen dafür, dass da so viele Pakete drüber gehen. War schon Anfang dieses Jahres, ja. Genau, aber glücklicherweise hatte dann PirateBay, die auch ähnliche Probleme hatten, dass ihr Tracker auch nicht so schnell war, haben dann das Programm entdeckt und haben es dann bei sich installiert und fanden es total toll und dann durften wir mit unserem eigenen offenen Tracker auf einen von ihren Servern ziehen.
Und so zufrieden, wie du diesen Satz gerade beendet hast, mit den unterschiedlichen Aspekten zwischendurch, scheint die Büchse zu laufen, um es ganz volkszümlich zu sagen.
Mehrere Büchse, die bei PirateBay hatten am Anfang irgendwie 16 Rechner oder so. Inzwischen sind es nur noch 10, weil unsere Software so viel besser ist, dass sie sich ein paar Rechner einsparen konnten.
Und das bei noch mehr Kunden. Du wolltest gerade eine Frage stellen.
Nee, du warst durch mit deinem. Dann würde ich nämlich wieder in die Telefonleiste greifen. 0331 70 97 110. Wir haben eine Anfrage von Bernd. Hallo Bernd, guten Abend.
Hallo Abend. Die Post, die Aztereu zum Beispiel aufmacht, kann da jemand anderes von außerhalb auf meinen Rechner zugreifen?
Nein, der kann halt nur, dein BitTorrent-Programm macht ja diesen Port auf. Und dann können die natürlich von außen auf dein BitTorrent zugreifen. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie File XY irgendwie da drüber anbietest und die auch genau das haben wollen, dann können die sich mit dir austauschen. Aber das ist ja auch Sinn der Sache. Aber wenn die schon sich wegen irgendwas anderem connecten oder sogar ein anderes File, dann kriegen die es nicht. Erstens hast du es wahrscheinlich gar nicht. Und zweitens würde das BitTorrent-Programm sagen, ne, das kann ich nicht und kann ich nicht annehmen.
Also durch den Ruder könnt ihr nicht durchgreifen. Und über den Alter Port geht nur in eine Richtung sozusagen.
Ne, der geht in beide Richtungen. Aber dein BitTorrent-Client würde sozusagen anfragen, die da ankommen, mit denen er nichts anfangen kann, die wirft er weg.
Also mit so einem IP-Scanner oder so kann da keiner zugreifen.
Mit deinem was?
IP-Scanner. Gibt der IP-Scanner, wo andere Leute auf andere Hände greifen.
Ein Portscanner meinst du? Ja doch, kann er. Also dann sieht er, wenn deine Firewall den Port an deinen BitTorrent kleinen durchreicht, dann kann er auch sehen, dass da ein Port offen ist. Aber das bringt in dem ersten Moment mal noch nichts.
Ich glaube die Frage von Bernd zielt nochmal auf das vorhin kurz angesprochene, die angesprochene Problematik, wie sicher ist BitTorrent?
Wenn der BitTorrent kleinen schlecht programmiert ist und der hat irgendeine Lücke, die man ausnutzen kann, dann ist es natürlich genauso wie jedes andere Port, wie Windows oder was auch immer, den man über einen offenen Port irgendwie angreifen kann. Gab es schon mal. Ja gut, aber ansonsten können die nicht dein Filesystem darüber einsehen oder deine Files sehen oder sonst irgendwas, sondern nur das, was du auch anbietest, ist das, was die sehen könnten, wenn sie die richtigen Informationen haben.
Also kurze Ja-Nein-Antwort an Bernd. Muss er sich Sorgen machen?
Glaub nicht.
Alles klar. Bernd, du kannst ruhig schlafen. 03317797110 Chaos Radio Teil 141 auf Fritz zum Thema BitTorrent. Ähm, ja ach so, ja, was auf jeden Fall noch auf der Liste stand, der Dinge, die zu besprechen sind, was will ich jetzt sagen, sind die häufigsten Torrents, die im Moment vorkommen. Du hast gesagt, es gibt 25 Millionen User im Moment mit einer gigantischen Summe an Torrents.
Anderthalb Millionen. Wir haben in unserem Trecker, ich bin halt so Statistikgeil, ich hab mir einbaut lassen von Erdgeist, ich brauch hier Statistik, machen wir irgendwie Top 5. Und jetzt hab ich mir sogar das auf Top 10 erweitert.
Erdgeist ist froh, dass er gerade den O-Source-Tracker durch hat.
Ja, die sind ja schon drin. Außerdem brauchen wir die, weil ich meine, um zu sehen, was er verbessern muss, müssen wir sehen, was wie wo passiert und wie viel und wie oft und so weiter. Und dann kann man so ein Ding optimieren. Jedenfalls haben wir da auch eine Top 10 drinnen. Und das, was immer ganz oben ist, sind amerikanische Serien.
Was für amerikanische Serien?
Heroes oder Dexter.
Also es gibt da Statistiken bei PirateBay. Es gibt da eine andere Website, die nennt sich taurenfreak.com und die bringen, glaube ich, zweimal in der Woche eine Statistik raus, welche die beliebtesten Tauren-Files auf PirateBay sind. Und da gibt es halt so eine Top 10 für Serien und eine Top 10 für Filme. Und da sind die Serien halt extrem beliebt. Einfach weil die Leute sie sofort sehen wollen und nicht warten wollen, bis es in Deutschland die schlechte Synchronisation mit den Werbepausen gibt. Oder weil sie halt einfach den Privatkanalen nicht bekommen, auf denen diese Dinger laufen.
Wenn man jetzt mal bedenkt, dass irgendwie, ich würde schon sagen, auch am meisten also BitTorrent von den Amis benutzt wird und die Amis dann amerikanische Serien runterladen, möchte ich nicht wissen, weil wir wieder von ihr, ob das legal ist, und so sprechen. Wie viel von den Leuten, die halt Heroes zum Beispiel runterladen, das auch gleich so im Fernsehen sehen könnten. Vielleicht haben die gar keinen Bock auf Fernsehen, oder vielleicht haben die gar kein Fernseher mehr. Das wissen wir nicht.
Das kann sein, oder aber sie haben keinen Bock darauf, dass die Fernsehserie ihnen in 25 Teile zerhackt wird, wo zwischendurch Werbung läuft und dann...
Das wäre doch dann schon wieder illegal. Man darf ja wohl Werbung nicht wegschneiden, oder? Das ist ja auch verboten irgendwie so seine...
Aber Tiwo macht das doch auch.
Ja, aber da wird doch schon wieder gegen geklagt, gegen Videorekorder die Werbung rausschneiden.
Folgender Vorschlag, wir klären mal ganz kurz, ihr hört ein Stückchen Musik, dann ist das Chaosradio gleich zurück. Luomo heißt der junge Mann. Kommt aus Finnland gemeinsam mit Sascha Ring aus Berlin alias Apparat. Love you all im Chaosradio auf Ritz am Mittwochabend, 26. November um 5 vor halb 12. Dennis Krügs und Erdgeist sind hier vom CTC und wir reden über BitTorrent. Sind schon eine Menge Begriffe gefallen, paar haben wirklich klärt. Der Tracker zum Beispiel, den hat Erdgeist wunderbar umschrieben als die Mittfahrtzentrale. Aber wir hatten das noch nicht mit den WearSites und SearchSites und MetaSearchSites. Das viel vorhin schon mal ganz kurz, da könntet ihr noch mal genauer drauf eingehen.
Also eine SearchSite ist eigentlich nichts anderes als ein Google, was in Torrents sucht. Wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel PiedPenem oder andere Seiten wie Isohand oder was gibt es noch? Torrent, TU, Mininova, das sind eigentlich nur Web-Server, die eine Datenbank haben, in denen diese Torrent-Files rumliegen. Und diese Torrent-Files, die kann man halt kommentieren und diesen Kommentaren kann man suchen. Man muss sich das wie Google vorstellen, aber nur eine Suche auf Torrent-Dateien. Und das Neueste, was es jetzt wohl geben wird und was dann wahrscheinlich so der nächste Schritt sein wird, ist, dass die Leute anfangen, wirklich auch die Google-Engine, die ja beliebt ist. Also Google ist halt einfach mal die Suchmaschine im Internet, dass die Leute anfangen dagegen dafür Applikationen zu schreiben, die dann diese Google-Search-Engine benutzen, um über mehrere Torrent-Search-Sites, die es da draußen gibt, also er sucht dann nicht nur bei PirateBay und nicht nur bei Mininova, sondern halt bei allen, die es so gibt. Und da kann man dann natürlich wesentlich besser Dateien finden, auch abgefahrenes Zeug kann man da finden und Sachen, die es halt nur bei dem einen und nicht bei dem anderen gibt. Und das ist so die Sache, in die es jetzt gehen wird wahrscheinlich, so Meta-Torrent-Suchmaschinen.
Also eine Suchmaschine, die verschiedene Torrents, die andere Suchmaschinen durchsucht. Die formuliert jetzt irgendwie bildlich an, also einer, der sozusagen alle Läden durch Co-Pros das geben könnte, und nicht nur eine einzige. Okay. Wie ist das mit den Wear Sites?
Mit den Wear Sites?
Na ja, was es wohl noch gibt, sind so geschlossene BitTorrent-Systeme. Ich selber bin auf so ein Ding ja nicht, da muss man sich irgendwie anmelden und Leute kennen und invite-ownen und dieses ganze Elite-Schnick-Schnack und so ein Zeug. Und da hab ich ja keinen Bock drauf. Weil das sind auch, denn das sind wirklich die Dinger, die dann hochgenommen werden, weil die übertreiben es einfach.
Die verdienen auch noch Geld damit.
Die wollen Kohle oder sind irgendwie so weit vorne, dass der Bond schon eine Woche vorher da ist oder so. Und da bin ich einfach nicht dabei.
Aber sind diese geschlossenen Netzwerke, um nochmal ganz am Anfang für die kommerzielle Umgebung, die auf die kommerzielle Nutzung zurückzukommen, nicht interessant für Firmen, die, weiß ich nicht, ein Software-Abdeck anbieten.
Von der Software her vielleicht, vom Inhalt natürlich.
Aber nur für die User, die diese Software benutzen. Also wenn Microsoft jetzt sagt, wir haben ein neues Patch für unser Betriebssystem, und das gibt es jetzt aber nur für Leute, die das gekauft haben oder so, dass man das abschließt. Oder bei WoW war das so ein Closing?
Also von der Software ist es für die Firmen bestimmt interessant, aber ob es am Ende wirklich so funktioniert, ist nicht ganz so easy. Weil wenn ich erstmal einen BitTorrent Client gefunden hab, der irgendwie ein Programm, was so eine Firma halt kommerziell irgendwie per BitTorrent verteilt, wenn ich den erstmal hab und mit dem irgendwie tauschen kann, dass der mir auch die Informationen der anderen Mitfahrer gibt, dann kann ich ja was runterladen, was ich eigentlich hätte bezahlen müssen. Und dann, das wollen die ja nicht. Und das ist ein bisschen schwierig zu erklären. Es gibt so eine BitTorrent Erweiterung der Clients, das heißt Peer Exchange. Dadurch können sich Peers untereinander auch noch Adressen austauschen, ohne dass sie die Mitfahrzentrale fragen müssen. Und das kann nicht Sinn in so einer Firma sein.
Aber wie war das bei Blizzard und bei WoW, beim letzten Patch für World of Warcraft?
Das ist ja was, denen ist es ja egal. Das kann ja jeder haben.
Das konnte man auch mit einem normalen Torrent-Client runterladen, wenn man den machte.
Genau. Also bei Blizzard macht es so, die schicken einem immer so ein Mini-Update, das ist irgendwie so ein Megabyte groß. Und dieses Megabyte ist nicht ein Torrent-File, sondern ist sogar ein Programm. Und innerhalb dieses Programms, weil das nämlich eigentlich ein BitTorrent-Client ist, ist auch gleich das Torrent-File und dann startest du das Programm und dann geht eigentlich ein BitTorrent-Client auf, so ein Selbstgemachter mit irgendwie Blizzard-Bildchen oder WoW-Bildchen. Und der fängt dann an runterzuladen. Erstens von Blizzard selbst.
Also um das Patch zu würzen, weil du hast das Spiel ja gekauft. Aber wenn es irgendwie neues Add-On geben würde, kann ich den Laden geben, mir die Software kaufen.
Das musst du sowieso freischalten lassen. Und dann ist Blizzard auch egal, wenn du den Patch runterlädst und aber nicht freigeschaltet hast, kannst du ja auch nichts damit anfangen.
Das ist denen egal.
Aber so richtig, dass es kommerziell BitTorrent benutzt wird, ist mir auch nicht bekannt. Also kommerziell. Dass Daten nur an Leute verteilt werden, die dafür bezahlt haben, kenne ich eigentlich nicht. Kommt aber bestimmt auch noch. Das ist ja das, wo wahrscheinlich auch BitTorrent dort kommen, also die Firma von dem Brand Kohnen, wo die dran arbeiten. Weil die haben sich ja irgendwann auch, glaube ich, Venture Capital von Warner geholt oder so.
Ich würde noch gerne einen Anrufer herannehmen. Wir hatten ja vorhin schon erwähnt, einer der großen Nachteile von BitTorrent ist, dass eigentlich nur aktuell verfügbare Daten vorhanden sind. Also, was die Leute aktuell gerade haben wollen, wenn du irgendwas brauchst.
Oder eine Firma, die sich halt drum kümmert, wie Blizzard das ganze Zeit anbietet hat.
Oder der Chaos Computer Club, die die Filme der letzten ganzen Kongresse auch immer noch anbieten. Veit hat dazu eine Frage. Hallo Veit, guten Abend. Das ist hier gar nicht genau zu sehen. Grüß dich, Veit.
Hi, ich hab eine Frage. Zum Beispiel so ganz alte Sachen von 99 oder sowas, Voyager oder so ein Kram. Gibt es noch irgendeine Möglichkeit, dass man überall im Web, also dass man halt das Server dafür abstellt, die dir die ganzen Sachen immer weiter sharen, dass man dann diese wichtigen nicht verliert?
Also, solange jemand da ist, der irgendwie diese alten Filme, welche auch immer das sind, weil Voyager, weiß nicht wie es so legalmäßig aussieht, aber wenn jemand da ist, der dir die ganze Zeit anbietet, weil er ein Fan ist oder weil er Interesse dran hat, dass sich die Sachen verteilen, dann sind auch Sachen von 99 noch im Netz, wenn aber keiner da ist, dann geht das schlecht und meistens lassen für alte Sachen, lässt das Interesse nach einer Weile nach, dann will es keiner mehr haben. Also zum Beispiel ein Film, ich nehme jetzt mal als Beispiel 2001 diesen Space Odyssey, der ist von 69, den gibt es auch noch im Netz, weil den gucken immer noch tausende Leute, aber irgendein Scheiß, den halt keiner sehen will, den gibt es auch nicht. Aber das ist eigentlich mit allen Sachen so, oder?
Wenn sich der rechte Inhaber von Voyager dazu bequemen würde, dass die Fans noch weiter die Serie sehen können, dann würde er dafür sorgen, dass im BitTorrent die Voyager-Folgen immer noch verfügbar wären.
Veit, du siehst auch hier greift das alte Oma Stichwort, die Kette ist immer nur so stark wie ihr schlechtes Glied.
Wird am diesjährigen CZT über BitTorrent gesprochen?
Also wir haben keinen Vortrag eingebracht.
Nicht von uns, wenn es jemand macht, aber ich habe bisher nichts gesehen, glaube ich. Und wir wollten nicht das Gleiche wie im letzten Jahr erzählen, weil irgendwann ist es auch nicht mehr so spannend. Vielleicht im nächsten Jahr wieder.
Nein.
Alter, wir haben eine Grußsendung und eine Wunschsendung bei Fritz. Schick ihm ne Mail. MeinFritz.de heißt die. Läuft jeden Tag zwischen 19 und 20 Uhr. Da kannst du das machen. Und der eigentliche Trick, den verrate ich jetzt mal, ist nicht zu sagen, kann ich noch jemanden grüßen, sondern ich würde gerne mal Paul Erwin, Egon und Willi grüßen. Dann ist das in Ordnung. Dann würde ich sagen, ist natürlich nicht in Ordnung. Feiert dir einen schönen Abend.
Und Paul und Volker, mein schwules Bärchen, begrüße ich noch sehr.
Ciao.
Manchen ist ihre Musik zu anti. Anderen ist ihre Bühnenshow. Aber die meisten kriegen einfach nicht too much von diesem Anti. Die Gewinner des Radio Awards für neue. Live in Berlin und Live in Cottbus. Wann genau und wo genau? Genau. Sind Sie too much? Seid ihr zu.
Bei Terroranschlägen im indischen Bombay sind bis zu 80 Menschen ums Leben gekommen. Mehr als 200 wurden verletzt. Das berichten indische Behörden. Ein Verwaltungssprecher teilte mit, dass auch mehrere Ausländer als Geiseln verschleppt worden sind. Die Attentäter griffen verschiedene Luxushotels, einen Café, einen gelebten Bahnhof und eine Tankstelle an. In einem der Hotels befanden sich offenbar auch EU-Politiker. Ob unter den Opfern auch Deutsche sind, ist immer noch nicht geklärt. Zu den Anschlägen hat sich in verschiedenen E-Mails eine islamistische Gruppe bekannt. In Thailand halten Regierungsgegner weiter den Flughafen in Bangkok besetzt. Hunderte Flüge wurden abgesagt, tausende Urlauber sitzen fest. Mit der Aktion wollten die Demonstranten die Rückkehr vom thailändischen Ministerpräsidenten Somchai von einer Auslandsreise verhindern. Er landete aber stattdessen auf eine Militärflughafen im Norden des Landes. Die Regierungsgegner werfen Ministerpräsident Somchai unter anderem Korruption vor und verlangen deshalb auch seinen Rücktritt. In diesem Wintersemester gibt es offenbar so viele Studienanfänger wie noch nie. Die Wochenzeitung Die Zeit hat ausgerechnet, dass sich 334.000 junge Leute neu eingeschrieben haben. Das sind gut 6% mehr als im letzten Jahr. Demnach haben vor allem das Saarland, Hessen und Hamburg bei den Studienanfängern zugelegt. Aber auch in Brandenburg gab es einen Studentenansturm. Die Zahlen will das Statistische Bundesamt am Montag offiziell rausgeben. Werder Bremen muss sich aus der Champions League verabschieden. Die Bremer kamen bei Anautosis Famagusta lediglich zu einem 2 zu 2. Damit blieben sie auch im fünften Spiel ohne Sieg. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen heute Nacht in Frankfurt und Cottbus haben wir 3 Grad, Potsdam und Angermünde 4, Neurupien 5, Wittenberge 6 und auch in Berlin sind es 5 Grad. Heute Nacht ist es stark bewölkt. Es gibt immer wieder Regen oder auch Sprühregen und die Temperaturen gehen bis auf 2 Grad runter. Auch am Tag ist es ziemlich bewölkt. Vor allem im Norden kann es noch etwas regnen. In südlicher Richtung kommt auch mal die Sonne raus. Das Ganze dann bei maximal 7 Grad. Mit einer Meldung aus dem Stadtverkehr Berlin immer noch auf der A100 Stadtring Richtung Wedding zwischen Spandauer Damm und dem Siemens Damm 1 Kilometer Stau. Wir wünschen euch eine gute Fahrt.
Und wenn im Radio 89, 85, dann Fritz in Berliner Kabel.
Blum, die Zeitsprechstunden.
Der Chaos Computer Club begrüßt euch zum Chaos Radio. Achso, der hängt direkt vor deiner Nase. Das Ding, wo die rote Lampe darüber leuchtet. Und wenn du da reinsprichst, können wir dich alle hören. Also Erdgeist war das, der ist schon da. Dennis und Kröck sind auch hier. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir reden heute über BitTorrent und haben vorhin ja ganz kurz schonmal angewähnt, dass mittlerweile mehr als 50% des Traffic, der im Netz passiert, per Torrent betrieben wird, wo natürlich jeder handelsübliche DSL-Handbieter, der euch eine Flatrate zur Verfügung stellt, vor Schreck in die Hände klatscht. Was passiert denn da genau?
Ja, eigentlich sollten sie sich ja freuen, dass die Leute anfangen, ihr DSL zu benutzen und auch dieses Internet mal zu benutzen. Aber das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Sie müssen ja den Traffic, den sie an die Endkunden weitergeben, die müssen sie auch irgendwo einkaufen. Die müssen sie irgendwo bezahlen. Und wenn man zu Hause eine Flatrate hat, dann zahlt man den selber nicht. Da zahlt man dann 20 Euro im Mond und das ist gut. Und wenn man da jetzt aber die 16 MBit 24-7 dichtmacht, dann muss der Provider das irgendwo einkaufen. Und die verschiedene Provider haben jetzt angefangen, das nicht mehr so gut zu finden und rauszufinden, was dann jetzt eigentlich diesen Traffic produziert. Und sind darauf gekommen, okay, es ist tatsächlich bitter und was bei uns diese Probleme verursacht. Deswegen wir so viel Traffic einkaufen müssen, den wir gar nicht refinanziert bekommen durch das 20 Euro, die wir im Preis erhöhen, das klingt erstmal nach Preiserhöhungen, kann man aber nicht machen, der Markt ist hart. Es gibt immer jemanden, der weniger für seinen DSL-Anschluss haben will. Und die Provider haben halt angefangen BitTorrent zu shapeen. Sie fangen also an, das Protokoll zu erkennen und fangen dann an die Datenrate runter zu drehen. Sie werfen Pakete weg oder halten sie eine Weile auf.
Also das merke ich dann daran, dass es mehr dauert?
Das merkt man dann daran, dass da keine vernünftige Datenrate zustande kommt, dass man da nicht mehr als einen Megabyte pro Sekunde runterladen kann oder ein Mbit oder so. Und dann sitzt man halt doof da und es ist schon mehrfach vorgekommen, dass große Providers das getan haben. In Amerika war es wohl der DSL Provider Comcast, der da im Gespräch war, der hat das getan. In Deutschland, weiß ich gar nicht, ob es da auch schon einen Fall gab. Jedenfalls ist es ein Problem. Kabel Deutschland war das, glaube ich.
Das Problem ist ja auch, dass die Leute nicht nur runterladen, weil die haben ja 16 Mbit, können ja viel runterladen, sondern die schicken ja auch alle noch hoch, weil jeder tauscht ja mit jedem, es ist ja peer-to-peer. Und das mögen die auch gar nicht. Das kostet nämlich auch richtig.
Aber da gibt es jetzt einen Ansatz dagegen, was zu tun? Also den Ansatz für die BitTorrent-Benutzer, was dagegen zu tun?
Wir haben nämlich dann angefangen, irgendein BitTorrent-Protokoll, Kryptographie einzubauen. Das ist so dasselbe, was du machst, wenn du mit deiner Bank so Transaktionen machst. Dann machst du ja auch HTTPS. Und das ist dann fast wie Internet, bloß in verschlüsselt.
Fast wie Internet, nur verschlüsselt.
Die selbe Idee haben sie sich dann auch für die Verbindung von einem Pier, also von jemanden, der eine Datei runterladen möchte, zu jemand anderem, der eine Datei runterladen möchte, haben sie sich auch ein Krypto-Protokoll ausgedacht, sodass man vielleicht bei der Auswahl seines BitTorrent-Clients, mit dem man Dateien runterladen möchte, einfach darauf achten, dass die auch wirklich Krypto können. Das steht dann auf der Seite drauf, dass irgendwie Encryption oder Krypto oder so steht da drauf. Zum Beispiel Transmission, was irgendwie unsere Empfehlung war, kann das einfach von Hause aus. Und dann, wenn es verschlüsselt ist, dann hat der ISP auch wenig Möglichkeit, zu erkennen, dass es jetzt BitTorrent ist. Also sie können dann vielleicht versuchen, anhand der Muster in den Paketen, noch von draußen, also zeitlich, zu korrelieren, ob das jetzt BitTorrent vielleicht ist oder nicht, aber können sich auch in die Nässin setzen.
Aber sie sehen in jedem Fall, dass das Erdgeist immer noch genauso viel Traffic veranstaltet wie vorher. Sie können nur nicht mehr sagen, was du da machst.
Genau. Und da das ja nur die Hälfte des Problems ist, man ja auch mit dem Tracker noch redet, bin ich jetzt auch dabei, das Krypto in den Trackerverkehr mit einzubauen.
Weil zum Beispiel die ganzen Provider der Welt kennen, wenn wir jetzt mal wieder bei PirateBay sind, die kennen die Adressen von PirateBay, also könnte man jetzt filtern. Jeder, der eine Connection zu PirateBay macht, der will ja irgendwie BitTorrent machen, also lassen wir die Connection schon gar nicht zu, dass er gar nicht bei PirateBay ankommt, und das ist natürlich blöd, also will man da verschlüsseln.
Du hast gesagt, da bin ich gerade dran. Wie lange dauert das, bis wir das alle benutzen können, was du dir da ausdenkst?
Na, das ist halt ziemlich anstrengend für so einen Server.
Ich will mal kurz, du kannst noch drüber nehmen. Also eigentlich wäre Verschlüsselung zum Tracker ganz easy, weil das ist sowieso ein HTTP-Call, so wie dein Webbrowser das auch macht. Man könnte sogar einen BitTorrent-Call zum Tracker im Browser eingeben und würde dann das komische Ergebnis sehen, aber okay, das kriegt halt der Client. Aber da könnte man einfach SSL davor kleben, also hier dieses HTTPS, dass es nicht sicher ist, so wie da bei der Bank oder wo auch immer. Und dann wäre alles gut. Und das könnte man einfach so klick, einschalten und dann würde es gehen. Das Problem ist nur, bei PirateBay kommen so einer Sekunde 50.000, so eine Hits pro Sekunde. Und das kann man nicht verschlüsseln, weil verschlüsseln kostet viel CPU-Zeit. Und es gibt zwar auch Hardware, die ist beschleunigt, aber die ist teuer oder die schafft es auch nicht, weiß nicht genau. Und da kommt Erdgeist dann, weil der muss es hinkriegen. Das ist auch bei 50.000 immer noch funktioniert.
Ich sehe Erdgeist in so einem blauen, komplett engen Trainingsanzug mit so einem großen gelben E auf der Brust mit so einem Umhang. Hier kommt Erdgeist und er wird euch retten. Wie willst du das machen?
Wie ich das machen will, ist jetzt sehr technisch, aber vielleicht... Ich sehe mich eher in so einer Montage wie ein Rocky, wie der jetzt mal auf Klo tippe und mal in der Küche tippe und dann ist es nach einem Monat fertig oder so. Hoffentlich zumindest.
Und wenn das fertig ist und ob das fertig ist?
Das verkünden wir dann lauthals.
Das können wir dann auch auf PirateBay.
Beziehungsweise irgendwie auch bei cdc.de?
Vielleicht in unserem Blog, das können wir eigentlich mal...
Wir würden ihn mal zusätzlich anbieten, auf jeden Fall. Aber den wir bei PirateBay willkommen, halt umschalten.
Das war opentracker.blog.h3q.com. Gibt's da nachher auch einen Wiki? Da war schon eine Weile nicht mehr was geschrieben, weil es schon eine Weile nicht mehr so viel zu berichten gab. Aber eigentlich sind wir da... Ist das unser Sprachrohr?
Im Zweifelsfall verlinkt zu finden unter chaosradio.ccc.de Und da klickt ihr euch zu dieser Sendung durch, die ihr dann natürlich auch noch mal als Podcast ganz in Ruhe hören könnt, wenn ihr mitschreiben wollt und den einen oder anderen Detail noch nicht auf dem Zettel hattet. Haben wir jetzt die wichtigsten Dinge besprochen, die zum Thema BitTorrent auf dem Tisch liegen oder haben wir irgendwas Exzellenzielles vergessen?
Nö, das war's. Wir haben noch so ein bisschen Themen, die nix mit BitTorrent zu tun haben. Wir könnten noch mal zusammenfassen.
Das wäre schön, wenn du noch mal eine Schleife um das Paket machst, damit was alle mitnehmen können.
Genau, wir hatten noch einen Hörer, der wollte unbedingt wissen, welchen BitTorrent Kleinen wir benutzen. Ich selbst benutze Transmission.
Das ist eine Mailcom, genau.
Genau, und die anderen auch.
Genau, unter Windows nimmt man halt Mikrotorrent. Das ist so dieses Mikro, dieses griechische Buchstaben, links ein Torrent dahinter. Oder U-Torrent.
Azurios oder Fuse. Ansonsten zusammenfassend kann man sagen, BitTorrent ist halt ein prima Protokoll, damit man möglichst viele Daten oder eine große Menge an viele Leute verteilen kann, ohne dass man an dem Traffic selbst zusammenbricht. Also dass man nicht die Daten tausendmal für tausend Leute rausschiebt, sondern nur dreimal für tausend Leute rausschiebt und trotzdem es alle kriegen kann.
Interessant für alle Leute, die Bilder, Filme, was auch immer.
Die massenweise verteilen müssen und wo es auch jeder haben kann und es keine Beschränkungen gibt, sondern einfach jeder es kriegen kann, wenn er will. Und dann die Frage, ob es legal ist oder nicht. Es kommt nicht auf das BitTorrent an sich an. Also BitTorrent an sich ist nicht illegal, genauso wie Telefonieren nicht illegal ist, sondern es kommt halt drauf an, was man da drüber betreibt. Also was der Inhalt ist.
So wie HTTP nicht illegal ist, sondern die Dateien, die man über HTTP überträgt. Weil nichts anderes ist BitTorrent, nämlich ein Protokoll, ein Internetprotokoll.
Und legale Anwendungsfälle haben wir ja genug aufgezählt. Open Solaris, FreeBSD, World of Warcraft ist alles mit dabei. Und es wird immer mehr werden, davon kann man ausgehen.
Was sind denn die möglichen Aussichten, wohin sich BitTorrent bewegen könnte? Also was sind die Dinge, wo es noch Veränderungen geben muss, außer den Encryptions, die die Welt noch wartet?
Wir hatten vorhin ja Berlin Calling gehört. Und so wie ich das gesehen hab, wird das Album zum Beispiel nur als Download angeboten. Jetzt schnell vor, hier so ein Künstler wie Paul Kagebrenner will seine neue CD rausbringen und will die möglichst an viele Leute verteilen, dann kann er das halt mit BitTorrent machen. Zum Beispiel. Und wenn die sich irgendwann mal da noch ein Modell einfallen lassen, wie man damit Geld verdient, können wir das irgendwie auch noch einbauen.
Wobei es Berlin Calling auch als CD gibt, seh ich gerade. Kannst du ganz easy kaufen.
Ich hab das nur mal geguckt und hab den nicht gefunden.
Ja, hast du wahrscheinlich nicht geguckt. Er erschienen bei B-Pitch Control, kannst du kaufen für...
Ja, aber nicht als Download, aber nicht als Fest. Na klar.
Die waren halt schlau, die haben halt gesagt, okay, bevor irgendjemand herkommt und unser Album rippt und dann da einen Torrent rausmacht und das irgendwo hintut und wir keine Kontrolle haben, was da in diesem Album ist, tun wir das einfach selber. Und dann wissen wir wenigstens, was da so einigermaßen drin ist und was wir verteilt haben. Und wenn es das schon mal gibt und das irgendwie gut geseadet ist und gut verteilt, dann steht sich noch jemand hin und sagt, okay, ich ripp das jetzt nochmal und tu das nochmal irgendwie nach PirateBay. Das ist ja dann langweilig. Gibt's ja schon.
Also ihr seht, es gibt eine Menge zu entdecken im großen Feld von BitTorrent.
Gerade bei Künstlern, die so klein sind und erstmal groß anfangen wollen, da seh ich das. So wie Radio hat das gemacht letztes Jahr, fand ich auch super. Die wollten zwar auch Geld, aber da könnte auch BitTorrent, glaube ich, in Zukunft irgendwann mal zum Einsatz kommen.
Aber es war kein Torrent-File bei Radio Hat. Das war eine andere Geschichte. Weil bei Torrent hast du ja dann immer den Nachteil, nicht kontrollieren zu können. Du willst das haben, ich hab's auf meiner Seite und ich sag, okay, kostet irgendwie ein Euro.
Oder 50 Cent oder so.
Da gibt's noch keine richtigen Modelle mit BitTorrent. Aber ich denke mir, Leute, die Geld verdienen wollen, die werfen auch immer eine Menge Hirnschmal drauf und lassen sich was einfallen.
Ihr seht, BitTorrent ist ein interessantes Thema. Möglicherweise in einer der laufenden kommenden Sendungen irgendwann mal in den kommenden Monaten oder Jahren werden wir uns dieser ganzen Geschichte noch mal widmen. Wir machen das Thema BitTorrent jetzt erst mal zu. Verweisen euch auf chaosradio.ccc.de, wo ihr einen Podcast zu dieser Sendung kriegt und natürlich auch den Podcast von Chaos Radio Express, die eine ähnlich gelagerte Sendung mit diesem Thema auch schon mal gemacht haben. Und jetzt müssen wir uns noch zwei Sachen widmen, die noch anstehen, denn es ist das letzte Chaos Radio in diesem Jahr. Im Dezember gibt's keins. Denn vom 27. bis zum 30. gibt's wie immer traditionell den Kongress.
Genau, und der Kongress findet im BCC am Alexanderplatz statt. Und Eintritt ist 80 am Mäßigt 35 Euro. Und wir haben wie viele spannende Themen. Wir ziehen da ein eigenes GSM-Netzwerk auf, zum mal damit spielen. Es gibt Vorträge über Pflanzen hacken, Züchten 2.0.
Pflanzen hacken, Züchten 2.0?
Na, das ist wie ein Nerds, die sich da mal intensiv damit auseinandergesetzt haben, wie man so Pflanzen züchtet.
Ach, Pflanzen hacken, also quasi Gartenarbeit 2.0.
Biotechnologie hat heutzutage viel mehr mit Technologie als mit Bio zu tun.
Und ihr baut ein eigenes GSM-Netzwerk?
Wir bauen ein eigenes GSM-Netzwerk. Es gibt einen traditionellen Jahresrückblick.
Ein eigenes Mobilfunk.
Ein eigenes Mobilfunk-Netzwerk.
Ist das denn erlaubt?
Klar, wenn du dir die Frequenz vorher geben lässt, ist das doch erlaubt.
Es gibt ja auch Standard-Hacker, die gehen glatt los und besorgen sich alles, was man wirklich braucht, um das legal machen zu dürfen. Sowas gibt es auch. Die Leute, denen macht das Spaß.
Na, die Amateur-Funk ja doch ziemlich häufig.
Das Motto kannst du mal noch nennen.
Genau, das Motto dieses Jahr ist Nothing to Hide. Nichts zu verbergen.
Ist das ein Fragezeichen oder ein Ausrufzeichen?
Ein Fragezeichen. Alles, was du dir vorstellst, was du da rein interpretieren kannst, soll ja auch zum Denken anregen, was man denn zu verbergen hat. Ob man noch was verbergen kann im Internet, das wir als Chaos Computer Club eigentlich nicht zu verbergen haben, was wir letztes Jahr so alles Tolles geschafft haben, was man sich dann auch in unserem Jahresrückblick da anhören kann.
Und die Ultimate C64 Talk.
Und es gibt den Ultimate C64 Talk, das werde ich mir dann um die mal wohlwollend angucken.
Da gibt es bestimmt einen 64er mit Internetanschluss und wahrscheinlich sogar mit BitTorrent.
Wir müssen doch den Datendaten noch mal sagen.
Mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit. Lass uns das eine kurz zu Ende machen. Also, wenn euch Pflanzen hacken, also Gartenarbeit, Biotechnologie zwischen 2.0, interessiert der C64 Talk oder das eigen angefertigte GSM Netzwerk vom Chaos Computer Club, dann macht euch vom 27. bis zum 30. Dezember auf den Weg nach Berlin ins BCC, das ist direkt am Alexanderplatz, unter dem Motto Nothing to Hide, der diesjährige Kongress.
Da wo die große Rakete steht.
Genau, und wir haben noch einen Überraschungsvortrag zum Ende, den wir aber noch nicht verraten dürfen. Der ganz besonders lustig und spannend ist.
Okay, also wer nicht da ist, ist selber schuld.
Der ist selber schuld.
Krüß, jetzt kannst du was zum Datengarten sagen.
Hier steht auf meinem Zettel noch, wir sollen den Datengarten morgen ansagen.
Was heißt hier steht auf meinem X? Wir sollen, du möchtest.
Ja, wir möchten ihn ansagen. Morgen findet in unseren allerwerten Club-Lokalitäten ein Datengarten statt und zwar zu dem Thema Solarsegler. Das ist an der Marienstraße 11 in 10117 Berlin. Das ist in Mitte, um die Ecke vom S-Bahn auf Friedrichstraße.
Wenn du jetzt noch erklärst, was ein Datengarten ist, ob da jeder kommen kann, der Bock hat und ob ein Solarsegler ist.
Also generell kann eigentlich Donnerstag sowieso in unsere Club-Rolle jeder kommen, der will und uns Löchern nachfragen oder einfach entspannt rum sitzen und klicken.
Donnerstags den Tag, der auf der Tür jeden Donnerstag.
Und Datengarten ist quasi die Erweiterung davon. Dort findet ein Vortrag statt. Jemand kommt und hält einen Vortrag auf dem Beamer und ist der Abend sozusagen einem Thema gewidmet.
Morgen Solarsegler.
Und morgen Solarsegler, genau, und da spricht Karin Remaikes. Und die hat, hier steht, für Planetary Society...
Also Solarsegler. Das ist so was...
Es gibt's doch, morgen wird's auch erklärt.
Das ist total spannend. Das ist so ein Raumschiff, was einfach große Sonnensegel aufspannt und sich vom Sonnenwind durch die Gegend blasen lässt. Und dann... Und das erste Projekt, was so finanziert worden ist, vor zwei oder drei Jahren, das war irgendwie das Cosmos-1-Projekt. Und die haben da versucht, einen Solarsegler zu bauen. Ich glaube, das hat irgendwie nicht so ganz geklappt. Aber das könnt ihr euch dann morgen im Datengarten anhören. Der offene Donnerstag beim CCCB geht immer 17 Uhr los. Und wenn genug Leute da ist, wahrscheinlich 18, 19 Uhr, geht der Vortrag dann los.
Genau, nämlich die Hacker fangen jetzt an. Nachdem sie Drohnen gebaut haben, fangen sie jetzt auch an, Raumschiffe zu bauen.
Okay, ihr macht ja vom 27. bis zum 30. Dezember den Kongress feiern, hackern auch Weihnachten.
Nee, da müssen wir ja aufbauen, den Kongress.
Wenn sie es vermeiden lässt, dann bringt Geschenke mit.
Damit wäre diese Frage auch beantwortet und damit nähert sich dieses Chaosradio Teil 141 im Jahre 2008 auch seinem Ende entgegen. Euch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, für die interessanten Anrufe und Beiträge. Wenn ihr euch noch beteiligen wollt an einer weiteren Diskussion oder sonst die Sendung nochmal hören wollt, chaosradio.ccc.de. Wir hören uns dann im Januar wieder in der letzten Sendung, im letzten Mittwoch, im letzten Mittwoch im Monat im Januar, ist ein neuer Teil fürs Chaosradio. Dennis Krügs und Erdgeiss, euch vielen Dank für die Einblicke in die bunte, komplizierte, merkwürdige und auch interessante Welt von BitTorrent. Hier geht's weiter mit Night Flight, Maxwell Smart ist da, der hat DJ Hype zu Gast. Da gibt's also elektronische Musik und Beats, die im Kopf von Maxwell und Co. wachsen. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, ich schmeiß dich jetzt hinaus in diese Nacht mit Mr. oder Monsieur Oiseau. Bis denn, tschüss.